a friend to all
is a friend to none
the roots of Education are bitter
but the fruit is sweet
a true wisdom comes from listening to
wise people of ancient times
all of their thoughts and sayings
become a wiser version of yourself by
listening to these quotes from Aristotle
the secret to humor is surprise
through discipline comes freedom
we make war
so that we may live in peace
knowing yourself is the beginning of all
wisdom
some save as they should live forever
others spend as if they die right away
is the mark of an educated mind to be
able to entertain a thought without
accepting it
what is a friend
a single soul dwelling in two bodies
philosophy can make people sick
educating the mind without educating the
heart is no education at all
hope is a waking dream
to live is to do things not to acquire
them
to lead an orchestra you must turn your
back on the crowd
no great mind has ever existed
without a touch of Madness
it is during our darkest moments that we
must Focus to see the light
happiness depends upon ourselves
wishing to be friends is quick work
but friendship is the slow ripening
fruit
he who cannot be a good follower
cannot be a good leader
happiness is the meaning and the purpose
of life
the whole amen end of human existence
patience is bitter
but its fruit is sweet
to perceive
is to suffer
those who know do
those that understand
teach
he who has overcome his fears will truly
be free
the educated differ from the uneducated
as much as the living differ from the
dead
the aim of the wise is not to secure
pleasure
but to avoid pain
I count him braver who becomes his
desires than him who conquers his
enemies
for the hardest victory
is over self
poverty is the parent of Revolution and
crime
nature does nothing uselessly
it is not enough to win a war
it is more important to organize the
peace
happiness is a state of activity
the antidote
for 50 enemies
is one friend
the high-minded man must care more for
the truth
than for what people think
wise men speak when they have something
to say
fools speak because they have to say
something
the energy of the mind is the essence of
life
there is only one way to avoid criticism
do nothing
say nothing
and be nothing
learning is not child's play
we cannot learn without pain
without friends
no one would want to live
even if he had all the other Goods
dignity does not consist in possessing
honors
but in the Consciousness that we deserve
them
were your talents and the needs of the
world cross
there lies your vocation
fear is pain arising from the
anticipation of evil
the only stable state is the one in
which all men are equal before the law
anyone who has no need of anybody but
himself
is either a beast or a god
he who is to be a good ruler
must have first been ruled
happiness belongs to the self-sufficient
you can't chase after money
you need to go towards them
any form of friendship is to live in
conversation and Company
for two years a person learns to speak
and then for the rest of his life he
seems to be silent
all human actions have one or more of
these seven causes chance nature
compulsion
habit
reason
passion
and desire
in all things of nature there is
something marvelous
comedy aims at representing men as worse
tragedy is better than in actual life
youth is easily deceived because it is
quick to Hope
whatever lies within our power to do
lies also within our power not to do
courage is the first of human qualities
because it is the quality which
guarantees the others
never sleep with someone who doesn't
want to show up on the street with you
he is his own best friend and takes
Delight in privacy whereas the man of no
virtue or ability
Is His Own Worst Enemy and is afraid of
Solitude
time crumbles things
Everything grows old under the power of
time and is forgotten through the lapse
of time
poetry is finer and more philosophical
than history
for poetry expresses the universal
and history only the particular
don't trust a wife who lets herself not
trust you
enjoying communication is the main sign
of friendship
there never was a time when there was no
motion
we have tried to collect Aristotle's
quotes that will always take care of
your hunger for the true wisdom of
ancient philosophers his quotes tell us
a story of success true relationships
and art combined in one person thank you
for watching